we filmed  123 people since this is new york city  we shot new york city very international  city so it was very very easy to find  people who speak dutch  german italian spanish  turkish japanese was not a very hard to  do it was a democracy  and everybody got to get their own  favorite lines in everybody was able to  express themselves  and uh  have fun  it's show time folks it's show time  folks attica attica cut yeah  you talking to me  you're talking to me excuse me while i  whip this out  and me rolling rolling world and rolling  okay once more  i'm spartacus  i could have been a contender i could  have been somebody i could have been a  contender i could have been somebody  forget it jake it's chinatown i could  have been a contender  i could have been somebody  there's no place  there's no place like that  i'm luke skywalker i'm here to  i am spartacus  show me the money  show me the money  you